another contentious battle is heating up
between Jason Sudeikis and Olivia Wilde
Olivia is reportedly accusing her acts
of trying to cause her to go broke a
source telling the Daily Mail while
Jason can afford to spin his wheels with
filing after filing Olivia cannot
both are worth an estimated 25 million
dollars but we're being told the fact
that she's pleading poverty after having
a successful career is insane do they
know how hard Daddy's working to like
bring us more dead last I don't know if
they know how hard they know how often
E.T just spoke to Jason leading up to
the season three premiere of Ted lasso
and it sure sounded like co-parenting
their two kids Daisy and Otis had
improved when you get home will you give
your mom a big squeeze for me and let
him know I love her May any of us get
the opportunity to find a job where you
have so much fun doing it and if that's
the example that myself and Olivia you
know provide for them than uh you know
I'm happy about that so this is one big
happy family of course Olivia was on the
job last April when Jason's lawyers
served her custody papers on stage at
cinemacon
the couple was fighting over whether the
case should be tried in New York or
California One Source says quote Jason
has always wanted to continue raising
the children in New York because that's
where the family home that they built
together is
ET reached out to Olivia's attorney who
was not available for comic
[Music]